So, the multi-level page table
still looks at the virtual address
in terms of page offset and
page number, but
instead of using the entire page number
to access one huge table, it partitions
the page number into the so-called inner
page number, and the outer page number.
The outer page number
tells us which part
of the larger page table
we would be using.
The inner part tells us, which specific
entry in that large page table we
would be using,
instead of having the large page table,
the outer page number is now used
to index into the outer page table.
And each entry in the outer page table,
tells us where to find the so
called inner page table.
Once we find the inner page table.
We take the inner page number, and use
it to index into the inner page table.
And what we find there,
is the actual frame number to access.
Another entry in the outer page table
will point to a different
inner page table.
So pretty much what we have
is the outer page table
tells us which of the small
inner page tables to use.
And the inner page table tells us
in where each of the page tables we
need to look at.
So it seems like this is just a more
complicated way to access the page
table, but still for
every possible page number,
we will have a frame number in
one of the inner page tables.
The total size of the inner page tables,
will be the size of
the original flat page table.
And we still have added the outer page
table, which we didn't have before.
So, pretty much, we still have
the same number of entries total here.
And we have added something.
So, where are the savings?